but we wanted to speak first
to Miranda Divine she is of course a New
York Post columnist we spoke to her at
the time more than two years ago but the
censorship of the story she said since
written a book about a laptop from Hell
which is excellent she joins us tonight
Brandon Devine you are at the very
center of this story what do you make of
it
look I I think we've seen uh quite a bit
that's useful it's not really the
Smoking Gun we'd hope for I feel that
Elon musk has held back some material in
particular there's a tweet in which Matt
taibi says well he hasn't seen any
evidence that law enforcement
specifically warned off Twitter from our
story but that's just not correct I've
seen a sworn affidavit from Joel Roth
the former head of Twitter's trust and
safety he was meeting every week before
the election with FBI and other
intelligence officials they warn
specifically of what they called a hack
and leak operation a dump of Russian
disinformation and Joel Roth says that
in those meetings he was told there was
a quote rumor that it was about Hunter
Biden so they seeded that information
with the social media Giants if the FBI
did and that ensured that within hours
of our story going live on October 14
2020 three weeks before the election it
was censored now we're finding out a
little bit more that there was
discussion behind the scenes at Twitter
quite a and you know active argument
about whether this was a First Amendment
um a problem uh but we the other
interesting thing is how little Jack
Dorsey was involved
um he was obviously just blindsided it
seems by the people under him who were
intent
um on censoring this and I think we have
to point the figure you mentioned him
already Jim Baker Twitter's number one
lawyer who says he says that caution is
warranted now that's coming from your
top lawyer you're going to pay attention
to it he of course is former FBI general
counsel very much involved in the Russia
collusion hoax
what what's interesting is for the
purposes of today's story which as I've
said five times is still unfolding but
Elon Musk announced earlier that this
release of documents was going to begin
at 5 PM Eastern we're now more than
three hours yeah past that and we still
haven't seen everything that they're
going to release he said well actually
at the last minute we're getting some
facts straight How likely is it do you
believe of course it's certain uh that
he was leaned on by government agencies
just like everyone who tries to release
all the information is leaned on by
government agencies
yeah and the pressure has to have been
immense I remember just uh yesterday a
Wednesday he met with Tim Cook from
Apple who had been threatening even
though uh Elon Musk now says he wasn't
threatening but he was threatening as
was the White House that Twitter would
basically be wiped out by being removed
from the Google and Apple app stores and
so Elon Musk met in person with Tim Cook
they had a stroll around the pond of
Apple headquarters and uh came out of
that saying well apple is not going to
do that never was going to do that well
obviously it's some sort of
accommodation you would think was made
between the two of them and perhaps Elon
Musk has given us a a sort of a tailored
or redacted version of all the material
behind the scenes because I know from
the lawyers who were involved in the
deposition last week of FBI agent Elvis
Chan that there's much more to the story
with the social media companies and the
that top Twitter people like Joel Roth
the former head of trust and safety
basically the top sense of the top
moderation guy he he admitted that in
one of those meetings that Hunter
Biden's name was brought up so while
Mark Zuckerberg's being quiet about that
and while in this particular dump of
information from Twitter so far 38 or
something tweets so far there's been no
mention of Hunter Biden being mentioned
but we know he was mentioned by the FBI
to the social media Giants so will that
come out in this feed from Elon Musk is
he holding something back or is it just
that Facebook really was first out of
the blocks to censor the New York Post
and Twitter followed suit so I don't
know I I suspect that that I suspect
that Elon Musk has been leaned on and
he's kept a little bit of information in
reserve yeah well there's still
thousands of pages Warren Commission
documents uh under seal so that would be
consistent with the way things work in
this country Randy Devine thank you so
much great to see you tonight
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight